this is Jonathan Ferguson the keeper of
firearms and artillery at the Royal
armories Museum in the UK which houses a
collection of thousands of iconic
weapons from throughout history and this
week since it won our most recent poll
we're taking a look at some of the
weapons in the crisis franchise oh oh
this is good this is good uh but also
bad make sure to subscribe and let us
know other games or guns you'd like to
see Jonathan break down in the comments
section below right let's take a look at
the Weaponry of crisis
okay first up is a mishmash nothing is
the word I would use basically the frame
is all the P99 stretched to make it
bigger not anything in particular though
and the overall impression especially
with the with the suppressor or silencer
fitted
is and it's not this but it's
this if you've ever wondered
how the HK Mark 23 beloved of many video
games
comes it comes in a cardboard box
which doesn't seem to be fit the um the
gravity of the weapon but uh nonetheless
and then uh in our case at least we
don't have the famous light laser module
that the thing was designed for for the
US Special Operations Command
but we do have a compatible suppressor
which is rather bigger than the one
depicted in the game which has a very
strange design with holes drilled in the
outer casing which didn't make a great
deal of sense to me but they've taken a
big old chunk of P99 and mashed it
together with big old
offensive pistols I suppose is the idea
so that the the universal combat pistol
was a sort of personal defense weapon of
sorts because a pistol can be a personal
defense weapon in the role-based
definition of a personal defense weapon
and the HK Mark 23 was famously it's
described by um I think by the Navy
SEALS or one of them at least as a crew
served pistol because it's just so
immense it's considering it's only 45
ACP it is huge and that's the scale I
get from this kind of handles like a
video game pistol really not
particularly remarkable dual wielding of
course
um go back and watch me attempt to do it
if you will
um not very successfully you know a
super soldier in a combat suit I'm sure
you'd have no problem
foreign
this does not
look in detail
that much like an xm8 it's got a lot of
extra lines and and separate components
on it that they're at the xm8 from
memory does not have the overall
silhouette yeah absolutely there was I
believe a different rail handguard for
the xm8 because the standard version was
some sort of weird socket Port system
for attaching accessories I think a sort
of proprietary accessories will just
plug straight in I think was the idea
rather than what we have now which is
things like M lock where it's a slot
that takes a piece of rail that then
takes the accessory so you pre-configure
the rifle to then be configurable for
your missions so is the idea I think the
makeover they're given the xm8 does sort
of look right for the universe so there
are a few features of this and I don't
fully understand uh we have a an
operating sort of trigger group here
that means we can find Sammy we can fire
automatic so that's good despite this
being a somewhat fictionalized version
of a Infantry full it still has the
ability to change fire modes we also
have a weird infinite supply of some
sort of Dart which seems to be a piece
of equipment attached to the rifle not
really clear how that works if anyone
knows let us know or let me know anyway
all right make it fast all right this is
a grenade launcher equipped variant of
this rifle and we have some stats there
which look
roughly like reality although we have
this ammo four millimeter Sabo scar
interesting that that kind of implies
the standard round for this is some sort
of lechette type round I'm not sure
um what's amuse me slightly is that in
front of the very chunky magazine catch
on this thing in other words push
release
you don't generally need a description
on the weapon to tell you what to press
I suppose safety at the back there might
be somewhat helpful but even then well
no to be fair historically there's
usually an F and S maybe even the word
safe or safety but not for the magazine
so that's that's slightly curious all
right so the great launcher is fine
doesn't seem to have the modern
convenience of either a barrel that pops
out to the side or a barrel that can
slide and pivot so that you can load it
to up so that you can load longer rounds
if necessary or just for more convenient
loading this this seems to be limited to
the original m203 style slide it Forward
shoving around close it system so it's
like a sort of cosmetically different
m203 in in that respect it's also quite
proud of the gun if you see what I mean
it's the way it's attached to the model
makes it quite makes the whole thing
quite bulky whereas modern grenade
launches are sort of designed from the
start to meld better with the receiver
of the weapon that they're supposed to
go on slightly weird as well on this
variant of the crisis
I'm going to call it the xm8 is that
we've got we've got a bit of picatinny
rail on the top there fine on the
carrying handle we've then got a piece
that appears to be inside the carry
handle correct me if I'm wrong but it
appears to be inside and there's nothing
there's no accessory small enough to fit
that maybe a sling swivel attachment but
that would be a not an optimal place to
to place a sling Point that's a bit of a
strange design Choice
um and it's not on the xm8 I'm pretty
sure
thank you
so the weapon seems to be highly
destructive being capable of mowing down
hordes of infantry in just a few seconds
the weapon oddly features 10 barrels
that holds 72 rounds of 44 millimeter
caseless ammunition
oh
yeah each Barrel holds 72 rounds reload
replaces all the barrels
what was that if you remember that weird
box gun that was that was
G9 with the with the um the bullets were
like behind each other oh no sorry ah
yeah you're the the Metal Storm yeah
you're right yeah
yeah that's a that's probably that's a
good reference actually mini Metal Storm
it's called it's weight it's called the
typhoon
metal stuff
[Laughter]
right are you gonna put that in David
put that in
so really interesting gun this I I very
much approve of something different but
kind of based in reality with that that
um the Australian company Metal Storm
who came up with a variety of weapons
with stacked projectiles
but well caseless caseless rounds
actually with their own propellants so
there's no case to be ejected and this
they were stacked in either reloadable
multiple Barrel containers like we see
being reloaded here or actually just in
the barrel itself in the case of say the
grenade launcher now there'll be
probably a problem there in terms of
variable muzzle velocity because the
first one to come out is coming out of a
shorter Barrel effectively I'm not sure
they ever sold that and probably various
other issues it was electrically fired
caseless high high rate super high rate
of fire salvos around so this is
essentially it and yeah maybe that's
where the name comes from and then the
reload is a sort of
a little bit of a nod to the P90 I
suspect
s but yeah it's kind of its own thing
and it's probably my favorite gun of
everything we've seen
yeah
no piss off
I've now got The Crisis 3 version of the
SCAR or
sudo xm8 and I think it's drifted even
more away from the actual xm8 it's
really only the sort of silhouette of
the gun that's the same and all the
details look different to me the notably
the cocking handle on the xm8 was the
same as the G36 so you had the extension
of the the bolt carrier outside the gun
essentially under the carry handle and
the pivoting sprung cocking handle on
the front of that and just did the
general cylindrical shape of the steel
receiver inside the polymer on this that
isn't there on the India it's exposed
it's almost more like a pulse rifle
where you have the exposed bit of the
Thompson gun that's supposed to be
hidden inside the shell well here we
haven't what seems like a a steel
receiver buried in a polymer one which
is not how the xm8 was it was like a G36
the barrel and Barrel extension has the
the receiver molded around it making it
very very light this is in fact the the
mark 20 scar in universe this is not
really an xm8 it has that distinctive
shape of the carry handle and I think
the earlier versions of the guns are
maybe a bit closer to the real xma but
by this stage in the franchise it's
clearly its own thing the ammunition is
supposed to be four millimeter caliber
which is very small but four millimeters
that does imply and the word Sabo
definitely implies some futuristic ammo
like they had in the ACR program in the
United States well before the accident
but the cartridge case is coming out the
gun look just like 5.56 quite nicely
modeled by this stage and they're coming
out
in that video game perpendicular angle
straight out the side of the gun without
sort of spinning but they're coming out
at slightly eccentric angles each time
so it's not like a procession of
precisely oriented rounds each cases
each time as in sort of graphically
limited games or older games they're
changing it up but they're still not
crutch for all the very high graphic
modality of the crisis games they're not
quite capturing the Dynamics of a case
coming out of the gun and I always come
back to the explanation for this being
we want to be able to see the cartridge
cases and if they're kicking out at
really quite significant speed there'd
be like a yellow blur at most the amount
of screen real estate we have to see
this stuff coming out the gun you
wouldn't even notice the cartridge case
is coming out so it's a compromise I
think
okay or should I say AK yeah because we
have a sort of an AK here
now I Dave's checked me off that this is
meant to be North Korean so I have taken
from the racks one of our one of I think
we're lucky enough to have three of
these an actual North Korean Kalashnikov
rifle
how do we know it's North Korean uh well
apart from
sort of chain of custody
um you should just be able to see
markings there
so the selector markings are
Korean
otherwise the production differences are
very small indeed this is essentially a
Type 3 Russian AK oh except of course
for the the all-important markings on
the trunnion front trunnion I should say
which you can hopefully make out
there so you've got you've got the star
in in a circle stamp and then basically
a serial number which is alphanumeric
they're pretty unremarkable but cool
nonetheless and have a piece of uh North
Korean
militaria essentially but it does not
really look like the gun on screen this
is drastically different this seems to
be some alternate future tank that
almost gets uh sort of Cold War vibes
from it though a little bit like the
German Vega East German Vega which was
sort of meant to be a more advanced AK
design in the late 80s with sort of
greenish colored polymer on it and a few
bells and whistles this is even more so
so this has a what seems to be a
machined top cover with lots of sharp
edges well they say it's not meant to be
a robust base for optical sites because
I've just noticed the side rail so it
has a take on the conventional Soviet
side rail mount but this difference and
then we also have the lower receivers in
two parts now in Universe the reason for
that might be a replaceable magazine
well for different calipers but it's
probably just
aesthetic Choice very big chunky pistol
grip slightly weird muzzle device some
odd Furniture it still has the machine
slots the middle slots that's on the
actual pre-akm AKs or except for the
very first time that some of you will
know about milled in both sides just to
take some of the metal out where it
doesn't need to be to make the receiver
lighter so this has a take on the same
thing so someone has used the AK as
reference and it's
recognizably a Kalashnikov
style weapon but much like the other
rifle
different in every detail yeah and the
case ejection on this is hilariously
weak compared to the real AK which is
Infamous for kicking cases out as a sort
of well a forward angle at significant
speed because it's it's essentially
always over gas largely why it's
relatively reliable so just sort of
gently tinkling out of the side of the
gun is if you're okay is doing that
there's something wrong with your AK
all right
a railgun of some kind energy
well I say energy weapon it's a railgun
it's accelerating a kinetic projectile
I'm sure you all know by now not a great
deal going on here we've got these
expanding blue lit
rails are they the rails maybe I
appreciate the Scopes are going to have
standard reticles uh in reality you
would need to match a reticle to the
weapon type maybe with a railgun you
just ignore the um Range stadia that are
on the on this optic and you always just
use a Crosshair I don't know what I'm
kind of getting at is that the railguns
are supposed to be hyper velocity
projectile weapons they ought to shoot
flat out to their effective range there
shouldn't be any need to compensate to
hold over but with your typical video
game scoped weapon if anything that
effect is exaggerated and there's a
always a huge amount of projectile drop
I haven't seen that in the gameplay
footage yet so as I say maybe it's just
that you're effectively slapping on a
scope that's intended for a ballistic
normal ballistic type weapon onto your
railgun the ability to swap out
accessories on the Move by the way I
mean if anyone can do it a super super
suit wearing Special Forces Soldier can
do it but um I do wonder where his
pockets are
some sort of futuristic
guided missile system here command a
line of sight system
um or if you remember Half-Life and
various other games essentially you keep
the laser on the Target and the computer
will guide the missile to its Target so
it's not they're calling them RPGs I
think assuming that's what the uh
character in the game is referring to
going up but RPG has become a generic
term I suppose for any kind of
shoulder-fired rocket launcher but this
being guided I yeah I probably wouldn't
necessarily call it that what's written
on the side is in Korean what I think is
type or model 56 56 being in Arabic
numerals so I'm not quite sure what's
going on there whether this is meant to
be a South Korean futuristic anti-tank
weapon or anti-w whatever you got weapon
really because you can clearly aim it at
anything like if you can hit something
in the air with it hold the laser on it
it will hit the thing in the air better
than an unguided system but not by that
much I can't really speak to how this is
supposed to be working there's a great
big cavernous hole in it looks a little
bit over complicated for for what it is
but it does look the part I also noticed
that the the Munitions the WarHeads
whatever you want to call them that are
being somehow loaded into this have
written in English on the back attention
do not stand behind and that's probably
not the best place to have a back blast
warning on the ammunition before you put
it in the weapon you probably want that
on the launcher and in the training
but it's absolutely correct whether it's
a rocket based system or a coilless
weapon back Blast from these things is
significant they are open at the back in
order to handle the either the rocket
exhaust or The Recoil of the round if
it's a recordless weapon
so you do not want to be behind them and
you do not want to fire them indoors
unless they have been specially designed
for the purpose because they will take
out a wall or and or deafen and
potentially hurt the people you're
fighting with so a slightly amusing
video game version of reality there
is ostensibly a different gun based on
the name it really does look an awful
lot like the same pistol from earlier
maybe it's the better graphics maybe I'm
just paying more attention but the my
comparison to the um groups if you like
is actually mistaken because if this is
the same as the other pistol of a
different name but the same same design
then that is literally a Groove down the
side of the slide equally I don't know
why you do that it doesn't take out
enough metal to really make the pistol
any lighter I I do like the wear pattern
on the rear corners of the slide there
I've got a very nice still here where I
paused of the very well modeled
cartridge case that's in full 3d I can
tell that because it's not there are
still polygons there visibly but you
have to look for them and there's a very
visible dimple primer in the base of the
case there and some really nice Lighting
on it could that could possibly be the
best 3D ejected cartridge case that I've
seen so far in a video game initially I
don't always manage to pull was exactly
right to fully inspect them in all their
Glory
[Music]
now I haven't lost my mind so I'm
looking at the um inspection screen for
this feline which is actually a very
cool design maybe a little a little busy
in some ways but I really like the the
look of it it sort of manages to look
industrial but futuristic at the same
time I think that's the the contrast of
the sort of phosphated or whatever they
are steel components and the obviously
polymer components and the good lighting
and texturing and everything it's I
always reference wetter workshop with
sci-fi guns because they do such a great
job now the bad is that they've called
it a ball Pub
so unless that's an in-joke if we have a
British developer who likes to go to the
pub it's Bullpup
because it is a dated reference to what
they used to call bulldog puppies
bullpups this was a common turn of
phrase back in the end of the 19th
century first half of the 20th century
and then the sort of slang term fun out
of use and we forgot why bullpups are
called bullpups but that's why because
it turns your normal shaped gun into a
short squat arguably I believe
uh but still aggressive and ferocious
weapon I have a book on the subject if
you can I don't blame you if you don't
I've seen the back end of this thing now
and um the magazine is attaching right
at the back of the receiver which gives
very little space for feeding however we
do know that the um in a museum in
Russia there is the the corabov
tkb022 PM which is the the worst name
for for a rifle ever I think but a very
intriguing design it this the magazine
also looks maybe a bit too curved for
the rounds but regardless if we if we if
we extrapolate the curve out to a to
what the length it should be you're
going to start interfering with your own
hand and controls of the weapon this is
the problem or a problem with it with a
Bullpup firearm is if your magazines at
the back
same problem with a drum it does get
bulky and in the way
so I guess this is The Game's sort of
minimy type machine gun it does look to
be equivalent to 556 the game uses
different calibers as we as we've noted
unusually there's a sort of guide feed
slope going up to the top cover I don't
remember seeing that on a real gun
before you do you do get sort of assists
like that but that strikes me as a bit
unusual I'm not seeing like there are no
very clear design references to any
particular gun here but it's it's very
recognizably a contemporary-ish near
future lmg design I so I do appreciate
the way he's sort of it comes across in
the animations as quite a chunky clunky
machine gun rather than a rifle so it
sort of helps to set it apart from it
from an assault rifle then again the
guy's in a powered suit which you really
need to slam it with that much apparent
Force right I've just seen this is
actually supposed to be 7.62 this
machine gun so maybe I'm missing the sky
oil
the rounds in terms of proportions and
scale look more like 5.6 but 762 which
sort of explains its lower rate of fire
I suppose it's meant to be 550 and it
sounds like 550 as well I also think I'm
noticing a bit of it maybe an Israeli
Negev vibe to the furniture on this but
not really it's more more of its own
thing
foreign
forgotten what this is supposed to be
called in the game but it is basically
an MP7
um I think I've shown you this before
this is our only select fire MP7 and
it's the early pattern that does not
take
40 round magazines we have a 40 round
magazine it doesn't fit properly so that
was the first revision to the MP7 was
among some other tweaks reprofile the
grip so it would take the curvature of a
40 round mag but the gun in the game is
clearly inspired by the MP7 even down to
the angle of the trigger guard the
distinctive ears of the cocking handle
charging handle they've just changed up
all of the different features it's even
got the same I don't know if you can see
this
the same sling leaves
on the rear of the receiver or something
very similar to it
the Stock's missing and something in its
place that I don't know what it is so
the angle of the receiver is different
the real gun just has a straight back
plate essentially and it handles kind of
how you'd expect except without a stock
it ought to be a bit more all over the
place but we have a special suit to
handle that I guess so it ends up being
like a one hand I think is it one hand
or is he firing with two I have to say
but those were the guns of the crisis
franchise I must admit I've yet to play
any of those I know I know to my eternal
shame but some interesting stuff in
there we hope you enjoyed that
as you know I'm from the Royal armories
please do come and check out our website
our social media channels and come and
visit the museums that we have here in
the UK if you can in any case we will
see you again next time